you know it's important to be a nun
quoting I'm quoting somebody and I can't
remember his name but it's it's a it's
important not to be an alarmist but it's
important to be alarmed whether or not
we have passed the the cryptical the
cryptic tipping point that is is
impossible for me to tell you it's
impossible for most scientists to tell
you what I can tell you is that things
are progressing in a way that have
defined a trend and that trend has been
is in my estimation undeniably
associated with the development of the
of industrial activities and man-made
activities associated with our use of
hydrocarbon energy and our demographic
growth what I can tell you is that that
growth in in the carbon output into the
atmosphere is nonlinear and it is not as
classically progressive as what we would
love to be able to see because it sort
of moves forward but the trend is
definitely growing up words and that is
just undeniable so where is the cryptic
tipping point well you know there is a
general acceptance in the scientific
community that 550 parts per million of
carbon that is per air / / less per air
yes oxygen is is the is the cryptic
tipping point and that we are presently
at 430 and that we're growing at a rate
of about two parts per million per year
so this would put us at about 250 2050
as a place where if we were to exceed
250 parts per million we would not be
able the increase in changes would be of
such consequences that that we would be
thrown into an irreversible and
accelerate process of warming up I don't
necessarily believe that it's going to
take that long
I I also i'm not exactly sure that we
can be one hundred percent certain that
five hundred and fifty fifty parts is
already is the the cryptic tipping point
because we are seeing changes that are
being accelerated today in the you know
how are glaciers are receding obviously
the the polar cap is is melting and how
different environments around the world
that being impacted by a change in
seasons and by an increase in in strong
storms hurricane strength storms by
areas that are seeing in you know an
increase in drought while other areas
are seeing an increase in in torrential
rains and whatnot and we also know that
these processes are exponential that
they're sort of there like a
self-fulfilling mechanism and and it is
confounding experts I mean the
environmental science is relatively new
it's it's essentially 40 to 50 years old
and models computer models are obviously
becoming more and more sophisticated as
our interest is being developed in that
area and what I will say is that
scientists are being confounded by the
rate of change and so as such I am
conservatively siding on the fact that
there are looking at this and going look
we can project but every year and
sometimes every six months we are
reassessing our projections and you know
the IPCC and the the the UN the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has made some projections which
we revised within a period of six months
and saw some dramatic